[Music]
hey welcome to every damn day you want
to talk about a few different things we
do we're gonna talk about police's
they're gonna talk about golden
retrievers we're gonna talk about a
stolen fish tank and we might even talk
about two famous people named Millie
Bobby Brown and Drake okay so there's an
Instagram account called Midtown uniform
Aynsley please show that photo and the
Wall Street Journal ran a story about
how this is now the new kind of uniform
of corporate America a certain type of
bro or techie guy where you wear like
neutral gray fleece over your collared
shirt and the Instagram account at
Midtown uniform very funny check it out
what do we think of this I mean I close
I think show your personality and I find
this so helpful because I'm like okay
you're a bland boring man the old
uniform used to be like the blue and
white checkered shirt that was
everywhere on the train in Midtown and
in line for lunch at Chipotle every day
and now this is what you see in line at
lunch instead yeah how did how did this
become the go-to uniform for this well
the article said that like Silicon
Valley types who were like outdoorsy and
free-thinking like Tim Cook would wear a
vest cuz it would be easy to like go out
during lunch and like an orange torch
[Music]
yes everybody in the same that's that's
a pretty hot take on these vests yeah
anyone think they can outdo that hot day
I'm all for that yeah I think your Kris
is absolutely right not ensemble of
collective thinking which is very creepy
hey that vest looks a little suspicious
do you have a swastika in your back
pocket when you look at this you're like
whoa those people are so white is what
you're like a little I don't know I
wouldn't be surprised if Kanye stars
wear the vest if you like it but listen
to Chris you don't have to follow that
trend if you don't want to
speaking of treads this next story isn't
a trend it's about two guys who stole a
fish tank from a Petsmart by motorcycle
and then were arrested Aynsley can we
show that photo
this happened in this comes from Niles
Ohio from the police department there
and one of my favorite things about it
is that after they caught them on after
they caught them they ran on foot they
broke the fish tank and then quote a few
minutes later the cycle was found laid
down behind the street and the officers
discovered a nervous-looking male behind
a home who was furiously pruning a small
tree with his bare hands
telling officers he was there to do yard
work
is so funny and then he said that they
went that way yes so cartoony aspect of
this is cartoony the get away in plain
sight yeah I'm here I'm just pulling on
a tree and be like I'm doing work and
then they went that way all of that is
straight out of Bugs Bunny Playboy this
is like the low-budget version of shape
of water just two dudes I can't even get
a friend to help me move and this guy's
got a fish tank on a motorcycle that's a
true friend speaking of great friends
mmm this next story
Drake Minnelli Bobby Brown our great
friends you love her from stranger
things she's a child she's 14 he's a
grand man he's 31 but he used to be a
child star and he's a rapper so he
basically why this is in the news now is
that in a new interview in W Magazine
Millie Bobby Brown said that her and
Drake talk all the time he gives her
advice what do we think of this Oh
I mean it's normal right all of us are
around 31 years old we all have 14-year
old friends right whoo yeah we're as we
were once children you have a lot in
common like the case that he's making
like I was a kid once and he was a child
actor specifically he was cast under
Grassi when he was 15 and he's a rapper
she's a rapper she's a rapper yes but
she has like rap skills she rapped a
challenge oh yeah I don't think she's
sold an album yeah this isn't gonna end
well
I hope it does but it doesn't feel like
also just being famous and 14 it's like
such a bad idea
as a starter that's a bad idea
don't be famous at 14 do it so you see
it's a non-starter
I mean I hope that they are gonna break
the mold and be just a very successful
friendship but I'm like yeah it's gonna
go up in flames it feels like this story
has maybe Lester left us with a strange
taste in our mouth
so I want to end on a happy note Ainsley
play that next video how about a bunch
of golden retrievers look at all those
good boys and girls thank you this video
comes to us from Scotland where 361
golden retrievers assembled to celebrate
the 150 year anniversary of the breed
and also to set a new Guinness Book of
World Record for the largest gathering
of golden I guess you could set I think
they set two World Records the other
being the largest gathering of turds in
a yard basic white people love the video
of a bunch of barking dogs it makes me
really happy I don't know kind of the
same face and it's just so cute
do you think anybody would home with the
wrong dog you don't give them like a dog
means like flash
Jordan you seem unsure about this chart
are you do you think it's cuter now no
it's mean it seems like hell it's cute
in the video the five second video but
oh my god what hell it's gonna be around
that many barking dogs oh my god we're
always barking they would chill it and
smell them but golden retrievers
centipede love this let us know if you
think this is heaven or hell in the
meantime check out the YouTube community
section we've still got a poll going for
what Bruce Willis character we should
dress up as tomorrow let us know you've
got a couple minutes left to vote and
we're gonna do a different thing right
now hello I'm Jordan and once a week I
take a little more psychedelics than
usual and write in my journal these are
my thoughts just like how Valentine's
Day is a scam created by Hallmark to
sell greeting cards and perpetuate the
myth of love Pi Day is a scam created by
Texas Instruments to sell calculators
and perpetuate the myth of mathematics
pi day this has been
let me go cheese steak like salt pepper
ketchup mayonnaise Friday ins your
American cheese oh yeah I'll be there
it's like 15 mins yeah B then pick it up
I gotta film somewhere I gotta feel back
in my day first of all I want to shout
out the YouTube community who vote on
this topic
cuz back in my day everybody watched The
Fresh Prince of bel-air starring Will
Smith will played a high school kid from
West Philly who moved in with his rich
uncle Phil bel-air Uncle Phil was rich
enough to afford a taxi from Philly to
bel-air I mean that's like $6,900 turn
so I did the math it's weird I googled
it it's out there
according to the theme song Will Smith
fled silly as to getting beat up in the
schoolyard the question we all want an
answer it's how to his friend jazz get
from Philly to bel-air they never really
told you he just showed up one day
we love you jazz how did you get parents
loved Will Smith because he didn't curse
music
kids love Will Smith because he told the
world how parents just don't understand
back in my day Uncle Phil raised
everybody he became either your dad or
your uncle and everybody had a favorite
I said I liked the first time Fresh
Prince had a lot of great classic
episodes most people can agree that
episode when wills dad comes back and
then leaves again was the one we all
realize Will Smith was a megastar you
remember I'm gonna get to college
without him I'm gonna get a great job
without him I'm a man me a beautiful
honey and I'm gonna have a whole bunch
of kids that's what I'm talking about
that's the way we are love I feel like I
killed looking at
I don't think anybody else here agrees
with me but I felt like I did a great
job and don't act like you've never
tried to do that see hashtag Will Smith
challenge let's try it out we won't do
it
think about that episode it really got
me a little hello let me know choked up
be honest with you it's a good episode
that was just that was just back in my
day when I first got my dog I didn't
I've kept forgetting to take a poop bag
out when I would walk her cuz I've never
had a dog before and one time she pooped
and I like had to pick it up cuz it's
like what you know you're gonna be a
good citizen and leave dog
everywhere and I didn't know what to do
and then I saw someone had like thrown
out all this white bread for like they
threw it out for like Birds scoop that
right yeah did you know I threw in the
trash I mean did you take a second and
be like well see you tomorrow every day
[Music]
you